but what i had to realize was that i was
only seeing it through my own lens
so it was like a life lesson for me i'm
like oh [ __ ] because
my first reaction like everybody's
reaction especially when you're a guy i
feel like our ego
gets in the way because you feel like
you've done everything right and when
somebody still disapproves of it
you want to stop point fingers and say
you shut the [ __ ] up
you know but really in this case he was
actually very he was actually very right
uh-huh he was wow that is a lot coming
from
david so to say that on a debate that
in five four three two
one please close that door
all the way oh my god
hello everybody welcome to an episode of
the genius
brain podcast how is everybody doing
is your week blessed if you guys have
never listened to this podcast before
let me just reiterate to you what this
podcast is about absolutely
freaking nothing my name is david soh i
am your host
and today we have a my co-host is this a
new intro hold on a second let me know
okay
my co-host my fiance muriel song
everybody
i am now the new co-host that means i
will get commission
next time olympic complaining champion
gold medalist the best at complaining
and finding something wrong about
everything muriel's song everybody
that is what she's good at that is 20
commission you get
no 20 nothing my butt all right
that's what you get free labor is that
what you're saying yep just like every
korean household
my parents didn't pay me at all to work
at their store never have free labor
guys that is
not the right thing to do it's not free
labor when this podcast is what keeps
these lights on
so it's never free okay fine fair enough
yeah we'll talk later did you ever work
for your parents did i
ever work for my parents no
oh you never had to do like like go to
your dad's business and help out
ever no cause my like first of all my
mom's business was
a skincare so there's nothing that i can
do like assistant work office clerical
work she didn't make you do anything
no i mean because i was in elementary
like a first grade my dear i was working
at my parents tour
oh she went the moment i opened my eyes
i was at the cash register
my parents had me work that register as
like i think when i was like nine
eight months wow so you must have
amazing guest service
remember when we first met you were
surprised that i knew how to like save
money in korea
yeah just because i worked the register
that's right when when i first met david
um he's like yeah i know some korean i
was like oh great
and he started counting things in korean
and i was like hold up
hot off how do you know to do that and
he's like yeah i worked out the cashier
at my mom's place i was like oh
that's pretty cool yeah no i didn't help
anything
from my parents my mom wanted just to
make sure i shut up
i was at her clinic um it was just her
uh
and one client and for each appointment
so there wasn't really much to help out
my dad it was like a business i don't
know what he did
but it wasn't like where i could go and
help dude mario told me this funny story
not even mariel told me
her dad told me this story where were
back in the day
like her mom so her mom does like skin
care and eastern medicine type of stuff
right really really cool stuff and she's
actually done acupuncture for me
um but that was during this time
marielle learned this phrase in korean
for this
to describe somebody who was like in
between jobs like
yeah like you know as a korean man or
just like men in general like in the
past
or maybe even now there's a lot of pride
when it comes to like being a provider
in the house
can i can i please tell this story her
dad told me the story
and he was like waiting to tell somebody
this like do you know what my daughter
once said to me
okay so i watch a lot of korean dramas
right i grew up watching a lot of korean
dramas and i learned a lot of words from
there like for example
in shin which means pregnancy and i
learned that
from a korean drama so there's a lot of
interesting words that you usually don't
use in date on daily basis that i
learned
and one word i learned from a
korean drama it oh dad my dad and i were
talking this was what when i was like in
fourth grade he and i were talking and
he was
in the process of learning not learning
um
finding a different job and so i was
like oh so you don't have a job now dad
and then he said no i was like
oh so you're a peksu and what peksu
means is that you
are an unemployed person
but when you also say that it i guess it
has another definition especially to man
saying like oh you can't bring the money
in it's like you're not a provider
you're not a provider so when i said dad
you're a petsu and i said it with a
smile he was like
what the [ __ ] is like his only daughter
basically you can't provide for our home
and then she's smiling in his face and
just walks away and i've probably said
it multiple times too i'm
like oh you're a pixel she's like a
church telling everybody dude
my dad's a pixie dude but his job is
pexu
that's so freaking fun her dad told me
that story and you could tell he's been
holding that for years
i'm like dude i think he got he got so
hurt that he
he he he found a job right away i don't
know what that's good
you changed them yeah i know i did see
things i do matter
all right i think ah should we talk
about that david
yeah so today was so interesting so
just to give you guys a premise right
and people who have been listening to
this podcast or even know like how i
comment how i speak about things
i tend to do things not
it's how i grew up right how my mom is
how my parents i say things how i feel
and i try to do it in the most
respectful way possible if you take it a
wrong way
knowing that my intention was good i
really don't give a [ __ ]
i could care less it has allowed me to
be a very happy person and it's also
allowed me to create very strong bonds
with people
because they know that i'm very honest
um but
as i've learned through marielle being
together with her that there's a very
fine line between being honest and once
again being an [ __ ] and i've talked
about this topic
consistently on this podcast and i've
gotten really really good at it
right um you've gone much better i
gotten really good at it
yeah the thing is i am still who i am
and the pro
and the good thing and also the problem
is that everybody who's close to me is
also like this
so yeah we you know we definitely tell
white lies we tiptoe around certain
subjects and topics because we're being
very respectful
but when it comes to things that doesn't
really affect like the core of who we
are or it's just general topics about
stuff
we just kind of willy-nilly say our
opinions we go that's trash that's
[ __ ] whack
what the [ __ ] are you doing that looks
weird we say these things because you
know
because we know there's no evil intent
behind it we're just saying our opinion
about stuff that we feel as friends we
could say
now because i'm in a profession
where i actually work with my friends
everything that we say isn't done in a
corporate setting
i'm very fortunate because you are
working with
friends who you already have this like
foundation relationship
and trust yeah and so it's it's this
weird space where
i i found out today and i have i've
known this too right
but because in my mind i feel like i've
already done the steps to become
a lot nicer specifically through the way
i interact with people and talk to
people now
because you know i grew up a certain way
you know how i grew up you see me talk
to people
you see how we converse with each other
it's it's crazy when he
changes into his quote-unquote old self
i'm like where's my david
where you going you know we talked about
code switching right but it's like how i
grew up and
and you people could hear it now they
hear like hints of it right
but i've learned to enunciate my words
slow down the way that i speak
uh i used to speak if people think i
talk fast now i used to speak way faster
talk the way that you i am i think i'm
doing it right now
um well not with the all the accents i
don't know
i don't know if it's an accident or not
but we talk about code switching right
where
sometimes we do things where uh we speak
in a way that makes either you feel more
comfortable or somebody else feel more
comfortable
but the problem with that in a corporate
slash working setting
is that when i because i've been in my
own world for so long
i think that everybody conducts
themselves the way that i do which isn't
true
right very true it's not it's not true
at all i've just been very fortunate
with the business partners that i've had
yeah that they all communicate just like
me yeah we don't have personal feelings
when it comes to ideas or thoughts if
ideas are bad or whatever
somebody goes the idea is not that good
it's dumb like we gotta do something
else
nobody takes it personally you just go
yeah i can see that but how about this
and then we do that that back and forth
cause that's also how it's like in
in uh writing rooms too yeah i mean i
think you were very fortunate that you
found a circle where you guys are
kind of similar like you guys don't
really have hard feelings no one's like
super sensitive no one comes from a
background where it's like very pc
you guys all came from uh not rough but
like very
uh transparent where they're like if
something gets thrown on me i'm like
okay i'm not gonna take it personal and
then just keep moving out and that's
great
but david is now expanding his business
to other folks that is
not in your in his circle so what that
means is that
there are going to be other
personalities coming in and
even though david is out there everybody
knows him like he knows the personality
like
he still needs to figure out how to
navigate properly so that
the message that he's trying to portray
doesn't come off the wrong way because
not everybody will understand
from the get-go especially not no not
building that relationship with you
yeah so like in business terms like the
way that i speak so casually
because other people have worked in a
corporate setting it gets interpreted
interpreted so differently because
corporate people
they [ __ ] a lot they say things and
they they're kind of tiptoeing all the
time
let me rephrase that david in corporate
we try to make things
as neutral as possible they [ __ ] a
lot and they took totally
i don't know they [ __ ] but this is a
great example
this is a
this is great what i was trying to do
i'm going to rephrase it
corporate side this is how we would say
say it but in david's world
you'll say [ __ ] if we say that we'll
probably get five see and it means the
same thing
yes and i don't have any emotions behind
it i'm just saying it like how it is
yeah it's just like in the corporate
world like this yeah people
read and interpret things so differently
they can't take things for face value
accept it and move on it's like well
what did that mean why did they say that
is it because they don't think i'm
adequate
well who do they say that to did they
say that to jimmy over there jimmy come
here let me talk to you for a second
read this read this
this is exactly the reason why we make
it as neutral so that there is no
questions like this that we need to
follow up with and this is what we're
practic like we practice doing this and
this is what we're used to so those who
people who are
used to this kind of conversation
especially on emails
or working with working on business
going to your world
and being so like blunt i might it might
take it the wrong way yeah i mean
like i have my hands in quite a few
businesses and like i've been finding
out recently like the way that i
communicate
it's it's it's not what how people are
used to except for
certain people within the group right
and because we've communicated like that
for so long
like uh recently i had like this email
conversation which
in my mind it was like a super nice
email right
and i'm the type of person that if i
have a problem with somebody
i'd say to their face like we have to
have face-to-face conversation
because i want to see what's up and what
you're about right because a lot of
people can hide through words we see
that [ __ ] on twitter we see it on
youtube
and now it's like that in emails i don't
know this i'm not a part of this like
corporate jargon world
yeah so when people see me face to face
they could see if i'm angry upset or not
because it's in my emotions
but a lot of the stuff in corporate
world if you don't write it a certain
way it always comes off
aggressive it comes off the meaning it
comes off like that's how people
initially react
does this person think i'm stupid is
what i'm finding out
right and in my mind i'm thinking like
everybody's just a bunch of [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
but it's just it's just a different
world right and because
they have to deal with that on a 24 7
basis this is this is how they
communicate
so i basically wrote out this email
and in this email i kind of denoted that
oh this is a good idea
but we should save it for another time
and
how it was interpreted was it was like
an attack on their integrity
yeah and when we when we spoke to each
other
i got a little heated because i was
shocked
i was shocked because i thought i wrote
the nicest email ever
you know and it came back as well i
thought you were being
the exact opposite opposite and i was
like
the [ __ ] are you it
it was a curveball for you it was a
curveball i was like and i was like oh
[ __ ] and it made me doubt myself i'm
like oh [ __ ] and so as we're speaking to
each other i'm looking through the email
and it made me double down it's like
hold on a second this is it
nice as [ __ ] in my mind i'm like this is
nice as [ __ ]
here's the thing where i [ __ ] up at is
just to go back at it
it's like yeah it was nice it was super
nice in my world
yeah and my world is very [ __ ] nice
in this person's world
it could be interpreted as demeaning and
disrespectful
because he comes from a different type
of function
function so i was judging things through
my own lens versus understanding where
this guy was coming from
and at the same time because and i get
concerned when people kind of get
emotional about stuff that's very small
but what i had to realize was that i was
only seeing it through my own lens
so it was like a life lesson for me i'm
like oh [ __ ] because
my first reaction like everybody's
reaction especially when you're a guy i
feel like our ego
gets in the way because you feel like
you've done everything right and when
somebody still disapproves of it you st
you want to stop pointing fingers and
say
you shut the [ __ ] up you know but really
in this case he was actually
very he was actually very right he was
wow
that is a lot coming from david soh to
say that
on a debate that the other person is
very right
i'm gonna take this moment what are you
talking about i say it all the time
he also explained himself very very well
too and like
i i think we we kind of met a middle
ground right yeah
it was like okay i understand what
you're saying but i also want you to
understand that
when you work with me if i have a
problem with you i will always say it to
yourself
face to face any idea when it comes to a
business in my personal opinion and how
we function
is that every idea should be heard
whether it's stupid or dumb or not
because people are going to contribute
yeah some way or another
and he's also you know i think it also
depends on whether
you're on the same level or not same
level and i think because now you're at
a stage where you're
trying to work with folks who are going
to be on the same level as you
who are not in your world anymore like
you got to have that flexibility
and be open-minded that everyone's not
gonna
talk like you or um
receive the message like you a hundred
percent and so like when i was first
listening to him i was just like
and this was again this is not his fault
this is this is like my fault but like
the way i grew up
like the only thing i could think about
was like you soft ass [ __ ] you
know
whatever
i i knew what he was gonna say as soon
as like i heard the tone
and the fingers going everywhere i was
like oh i know where this is going but i
also
i'm like man i do feel for the other guy
though because i understand him too and
i was like
oh yeah in this case though i feel like
when i look back at it
he he's it's a life lesson for him in
terms of
how i am and it's a life lesson for me
and like how other people
yeah i think you guys ended well though
no the thing about it is too
it's like this podcast is brought to you
by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals well my friends
you have not tried better help better
help
is offline counseling that is just for
me and it can be just
for you no more waiting around feeling
uncomfortable
in in-person therapy i personally have
social anxiety so it actually helps that
i can
access my therapist whenever i want
meshes them
at my time because i'm a busy guy
but i still need mental clarity and i
got to tell you ever since i have better
help let me tell you something man your
minds
your boys minds is crispy here's one of
the coolest facts about better health
not only is it offline
counseling it's actually more affordable
than in
person therapy and guess what better
help has financial aid ready for you
if you feel like you can't afford it and
i'm telling you right now
compared to in-person therapy it's
already way more affordable so what are
you waiting for
visit betterhelp.com genius that's
better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help
of an experienced professional in fact
so many people have been using better
help
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50
states special offer for genius brain
listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
genius it wasn't anger for me it was
more like
confusion like the hell did i do you
know yeah
and it made me question myself like hold
on a second did i do something really
[ __ ] up
did i am i am i [ __ ] up this
relationship with somebody who's
supposed to be a friend and a partner
right now we're partners but i want to
be friends with them because i respect
this guy
so [ __ ] much like yeah you do
i do like if you have like with me and
mario i show his stuff to her all the
time
he's always showing me something i'm
like who this who is this person it's
like it's the person who makes all the
amazing food and i was like okay yeah
but the question is do you have
relationship with him i don't and that's
the thing i didn't realize either it's
just because i
respect him from afar but i never really
got to converse sit down yeah
and let him know that hey i respect you
so much and i think that i'm doing it by
i never really question what they do
when it comes to food right
because i know for a fact what they
produce is going to taste amazing
that's how much i trust this person's
ability because of
that trust probably the case is that you
don't say much of their
ability and their fortes because you
trust it so much that it's not even in
the picture to have a conversation
you're like it's already good let's not
talk about let's talk about everything
else that we need to work on then
yeah it's it's weird man like i've had
the situation too
it's odd where you're so good at that
job that they don't even
need to think about it that they
sometimes forget that they need to
like others need to compliment them so
that they know that they're doing the
right thing even though they
like for example like for myself like i
know i'm doing my job right
but if no one talks about it while we're
going
while we're working on this project that
i need to keep applying
sometimes i'm like is my like
does my value exist here like sometimes
i forget whether i'm doing well or not
but because it's doing so well that
people don't need to think about it
they're thinking about everything else
or focusing on other things
that they forget that oh yeah this is
still happening
so it's kind of like you know kind of
like
i say like in my company where it's like
help help desk or
technology when the technology is going
great
there's no say but when it's going bad
we're all like
shouting at technology team i'll help
desk be like dude this is not working
why is it working why isn't it working
but when it's doing well
we never talk to them and i sometimes i
feel bad i'm like we're always going to
you when there's issue but we never come
to you to say thank you
yeah and it's also because i don't think
i ever grew up like that like you know
this
like my my parents never said good job
right we just did what we were supposed
to do and you're supposed to take pride
in the things that you do well
and you don't need external validation
from it right really your parents are so
affirmative
like verbal affirmation people no but
not not with tasks
not like uh like given things yeah like
i take out the trash i clean up i give
them money when they need it
that's what i'm supposed to do this is
my duty right and it makes and it makes
and it makes me happy knowing that i
could fulfill it i don't need them to
tell me good job and thank you i feel
good knowing that i did it
right so i think that's it's a good and
a bad thing
right it's a good thing for me right
because
i don't need external validation that
much it's not a completely
100 like that like yeah would i still be
creating all these youtube videos if it
didn't get somewhat views if i wasn't
changing some people's lives i get
validation from that as well
but internal validation for me is very
very important right so before i put
things out
do i like it first before somebody else
does and that's what's important
right so when i have business partners
or when i'm working with people
i i by to a fault i think that
this great quality that i think that i
have they have too i don't know this
absolutely not you know so it's like
it's like when i um i can do kickboxing
right
and then nick will be like hey you got a
lot better
it feels good but if i look at the video
i think it looks like trash
it eats me up inside you know it makes
me feel terrible i'm like dude i'm still
not good yeah i've been doing this for
two and a half years
and i still don't look like um like a
professional kickboxer
so it's like what the hell is wrong with
me maybe start
start with the diet there's there's like
so many other things
that that i look seek for in terms of
internal validation that external
validation isn't isn't a factor
i think a lot of people what i'm finding
out need needs they need external
validation
a lot especially from somebody who's in
a leadership position
especially someone who's new in
leadership too i think
that also because it's something new
that they want to make sure that they're
doing their job right
at least for myself like when i'm in a
new position or
new company you know i i do
like a quick um you know hot check-in
making sure that i'm on the right path
like if there's anything that they
it's alerting you know i but i make the
i make the i um i i become
proactive when it comes to those making
sure that i
go to them rather than coming to me
because when they come to me and
i [ __ ] up and i'm like damn it i
should have like gone to them and so
that i could address it before it
happens
yeah but that said like it makes me feel
good or
feel at ease when i do get that
affirmation yeah
so there are a lot of people like me
just know that you're on the extreme
side though you need a lot of verbal
affirmation i do
you need a lot of it ah
i do because i feel like i grew up
getting false
validation what do you mean um
i feel like people gave me verbal
affirmation just because they thought i
needed it rather than
i deserved it if that makes sense
so for example like i grew up you know
my academic wasn't that great
not because i'm dumb i think but because
i moved around so much from like
you know korea here christian school to
non-christian school so there was a lot
of subjects that i didn't really get to
cover everything like
it went from science to you know
christian revolution so like i didn't
i ended up not finishing the classes so
i ended up failing a lot of tests
but you know because you're in
elementary school and everything like
you're
okay to like pass it and move on to the
next
grade but because of that i ended up
like failing a lot of classes like i
couldn't keep up with them
and so um there was a lot of like
concern
on that end and so i knew that i wasn't
doing well
and so when i got validation
it felt like it was only to like keep me
going rather than
i earned it so i had a lot of like um
what do you call that
um i felt like later on
especially when i was getting into
college that i had to prove myself that
i could
actually do things on my own and it was
not until i got
i graduated from uc berkeley where i
felt like okay i do
deserve this validation now but prior to
that i felt like i was just like
faking everything and somehow getting a
like an easy pass how come you want me
to always give you verbal affirmation
because you don't lie
[Laughter]
that's what you said right you don't lie
so when i get it from you i feel like
you mean it
but i gotta hear it but you don't like
to say it a lot
so it's it's a dilemma for me well it's
weird because like i'll definitely give
people like verbal affirmation
if it's it's not because what somebody
else does
isn't amazing is if it's amazing to me
right like somebody could do something
that's dope right i'll give a great
example
magicians you know how much i hate
magicians
why somebody hate it they come up and
they're like hey pick a card
right and i'm just like get the [ __ ]
away from me right
so fun but it's fun to me in the right
setting
right like when i went to new york and
there was a person who
it was like this ninja restaurant and
the person was like hey for
entertainment can we do
can i do card tricks this seems fun i
don't like it when we're just chilling
having a conversation guys i'm a
magician i'm like nobody [ __ ] asked
the [ __ ] just what are you doing dude
yeah you know it's a little awkward a
little weird you know
but in that kind of sense it's like you
could show me this cool talent but if i
don't give a [ __ ] about it i'm gonna
give you verbal
affirmation for it it's very cool and
it's awesome
and it's skilled but to me
i don't care you know so i'm not gonna
give that verbal affirmation
when you don't care but ask for verbal
affirmation what do you do
then huh i give it to you anyways
because it makes you smile
i've been like i asked for it i begged
for it though
it depends like you but you know it's
hard for me because i
the only things only the only time i've
never gotten verbal affirmation from my
parents
you don't think so because every time i
go to your parents place
they always say things like what like so
glad that you know my sons are providing
like financially they're very stable
like they're so proud of you that's all
i hear every time
yeah like to me though but that's like
them saying like
how i hear it as it's like this is how
my mom says it remember
when you're younger i was just afraid
that you're going to die
you know but look you're you're you can
provide for yourself and i'm very and
they're very thankful that i thank god
that
you know you're able to to provide a
living for yourself that's a miracle
what are you talking about hey it's a
miracle yeah but you know when i was
younger i never got any of that
so it's like maybe hearing it now it's
even awkward i haven't told you when my
mom says i love you
yeah throws me off she's she's only been
saying telling me i love you
in the last like maybe five years but
you guys are so natural with it
i could never say it it's not natural
for me like for her it sounds very
natural she says she goes at the end of
the phone call she goes oh i love you
and i'm like i love you but when i say
it it feels weird
because i never said it verbally but you
guys kiss each other yeah we did we
showed love uh other ways though
right but the word i love you wasn't
something that we said in our household
huh it was only until recently but
before that it was like i would give my
mom a kiss she would give me a kiss
yeah she'd give me hugs but she never
said i love you so
the verbal part wasn't there and for a
lot of asian american kids the way that
parents show love is through what
oh i was like do you eat food
you know that's how they usually show
it's like always acts of service acts of
service
yeah your mom is an acts or service
person she always wants to give you
money
it's almost she's a robot like with her
you could i could tell i see this little
twinkle in her eye she goes oh i haven't
seen my daughter in a while
here's a hundred dollars like okay
okay now she can't give me food cause
she'll give me bad food
my mom is not the typical korean mom she
she's a businesswoman um she i grew up
with my grandma she's funny
and so she didn't really cook in the
house um so she knows that that's not
gonna be something she's gonna give me
so instead
she gives me cash yeah when i see her
which is nice um but it's it's yeah i
i also grew up not really hearing that
my dad would say in a
funny way but it wasn't like i don't
it's not
it's not a casual thing for us to say
nor hugging
oh that's so awkward yeah she has the
worst time trying to hug her parents
like watching her hug her parents
it's like her trying to hug sandpaper i
i love okay excuse me okay can't go that
far
but yes it is pretty hard to like look
at
um but i i i hung i hunger for it i
eat
because when my aunts do it to me or my
like friends or something like i love it
you know what it is like from what i've
seen from uh from an outside perspective
i think it's
there was no gradual come up it's out of
nowhere
like i was there to witness it it was
your parents would say bye right they
would wave
and then it went from waving to give me
a hug
i miss you make these jokes it's like
where's the uh where's the uh
where's the steps you know it's like i
think
your parents kind of have this thing of
they really love
you they really care for you and they
want this type of relationship and they
want these emotions and verbal
affirmations reciprocated back
but because you were never given that
when you were younger it's very odd to
have that relationship with your parents
so like like with your dad specifically
your dad's super jokey really goofy
funny guy
and he wants he says i love you he wants
kisses and hugs
but it's aggressive for me the way he
does it
there was no it's kind of like you just
kind of kicked your ass into a pool yeah
yeah yeah you know
the pull of love i think he would
totally do it go swim
you know yeah and it's like you're
drowning in it and it's not comfortable
yeah that's exactly that's a good way of
um
yeah visualizing it because my funny
thing is that my mom and i
we used to hold hands all the time even
when i go to bed
like she would hold my hand when i go to
school she will hold my hand that was
like a thing if i don't have it then i
can't fall asleep hold up before we
continue
let's talk about one of our amazing
sponsors babel my friends oh my god i
made a song for babel right now
babble if you want to learn another
language you better get your babble on
yeah that is unapproved but i approve of
it and i gotta tell you right now
that you want to learn a second language
right now maybe even a third language my
babel experience has been great because
babel teaches me the language the way
it's supposed to be
spoken not the way that it was taught to
me in high school we're talking about
practical usage
spanish my friends it's been an uphill
journey learning a language is hard but
babel has made it
super muy bien don't don't use that as
an example as me learning a better
language i'm trying to be funny right
now muy bien babel's 15 minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go other language
learning apps use
ai for their lessons plans but babble
lessons were created by
over a hundred language experts my
friends right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three
months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use promo code
gb that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code gb for an extra three
months free you don't know when that
happened that's so weird you i mean you
guys were
probably like puberty middle school you
know
but even with my parents when when i was
going through you know puberty
i never talked to my mom or dad i hated
it i hated it i hated talking to them i
hated everything
i didn't want to be around them like i
just wanted to do my own thing and every
time i was around them was when we were
at the work so
our relationship was basically these
people were going to make me work
all the time which they did i had to
work in the businesses i was like did
you kiss her
then too yeah kissed her good night
kissed her even though you hated
it i hated hanging out with them i
didn't hate them though
you know like i always remember one time
my dad just
[ __ ] roasted my ass because i was so
tired and my mom was like
yeah whenever we said good night i gave
my mom a kiss it was like probably like
12 years old
11 or maybe 11 so i wasn't in junior
high yet
i was so tired i went to give my mom a
kiss and i went to give my dad a kiss
and i've never gave him a kiss
i was just exhausted and my dad was like
oh you want to kiss me too come here and
i'm like
no yeah
that's so funny yeah like i was giggling
his ass off i was like oh god
oh he made it he made his day maybe he
was waiting for it he's like one day
he'll come over here
no i'm pretty sure he gave me kisses
when i was a little baby but oh yeah as
an adult
my dad said that my cheeks got so red
when i was a baby
because he kissed me so much that it got
not swollen but all right or whatever
yeah
so i don't know you know there is
something there though there's something
there for that relationship to have
gotten like
very overly affectionate to to
semi-affectionately
you know but i mean that's why i yearn
for a verbal affirmation from you
oh it's so much though what do you mean
you know what actually i take that back
she's not even as much verbal after she
is acts of service
a lot i she so for years she's been
telling me
like i am mainly verbal affirmation and
acts of service second it's
actually the other way around you are
acts of service to the
[ __ ] max and then it's verbal
affirmation
so i'll like one of the things too
because our relationship you know we're
working on relationship we're working on
communicating
and i've been telling myself oh she's
verbal affirmation i'm like good morning
whatever what
you don't say good morning i by the way
not all the time but i do a lot more
than normal
up once two weeks oh good morning and i
do all this other stuff i put a tally
down every weekend
whatever what not right i do this stuff
right and she goes hi i'm tired blah
blah blah she gets that
in the morning i go to costume pie i
come back with a croissant
you love me so you do love me
it's like a [ __ ] croissant and she's
like oh my you're the best
i thought you were verbal affirmation
fool i could buy her a croissant
and she's just like this man is the man
of my dreams
your acts of service i said it's both
your acts of service is here verbal
affirmations
here i i maybe it has
changed because knowing that you don't
give me a lot of horrible affirmation
i've come to realization don't expect
much of it
but acts of service is something new
that you're doing so i'm like oh my
media
i feel like i am actually service always
though you are you are
yeah like well um you've been
more during quarantine i think or
recently like
it's been more because like you've been
cooking a lot more
and like i've been being fed by you a
lot more
um also i think i really like it when
someone goes out and about and they come
back
for some and they bring something
specific for that
for me i'm like oh my gosh you thought
about me this whole time
it's not even the whole time what
happens is i met class and pie and this
is what i think
if i go to costume pie and i enjoy
myself and i come back empty-handed
she's going to feel a certain way i must
bring a croissant for peace offering
the result is the same oh you thought
about me
you're such a trained person dude it's
been such a journey like
if you guys are ever if you ever get
into a long relationship
like you think that you'll you'll stop
learning about somebody after the first
month or two
oh my god is it's a long a month or two
that's so sure what do you think i am
here or whatever vanilla
you thought that we would she was like
huh what kind of fights are we gonna get
into
i know little did i know you girl we we
fight we'll show you
fights dude i still remember that day i
was walking towards to your car i'm like
i wonder what am i gonna fight about oh
my god
i jinxed myself so poorly there yeah but
you were such a robot when i met you
though like you were you only had
rope not in the robot in the sense of
like you didn't have any emotions you
only had one emotion
it was excitement and happiness and so
whenever you oh my god yeah i was the
perfect kid
no you were not because when you weren't
when you weren't happy you wouldn't
express it
and it would brew inside you and i could
see it in your eyes like your face would
smile but your eyes have fire
and i'm like oh she's upset and you're
like and she would do something that
would
hiss me off which is when i see somebody
who's upset
and they go i'm not mad and then all of
a sudden she's just over here just you
see her pick up a cup and the cup is
about to shatter
you know you just see you see the [ __ ]
and the pressure cracks in the cup
i'm like oh you're mad and she's like
i'm not mad at all why would i be mad
and all of a sudden she just [ __ ]
chews on eyes
i'm like she she's pissed and she's not
telling me she's upset
well it's all about again this is where
um i had to go into david sews
personality david seoul's world
expressing the way he
likes me wanted me to express which is
just freaking yell if you want to yell
and i'm like i'm not used to yelling
i don't yell at anyone this is not the
way i find this is not the way i argue
and no one ever triggers me like this so
yes i had some trouble expressing my
emotion because
you were pushing buttons that i was
never done that that was never dealt
with
and again he's like if you're mad just
freaking voice up or like
say it scream yell and i'm like that is
not me
but you know i i adjusted my on my end
gone into davis one and yell and he's
like there you go i'm like well this is
not fun
not fun at all but now all he hears is
me yelling at him
now she just does it too much i need to
pull it back just a little bit
uh he it just he he's never satisfied
what am i supposed to do huh
i'm i'm a very satisfied person i just
swing on a tree all day
i know this freaking swing i made
what the heck you just need to go out
there and swing on the tree
it's too hot right now oh my god what
the hell are you talking about dude
i'm never satisfied she literally just
contradicted herself right now
i will do it once i have the time you
will have time
soon though i hope so that is the goal
it's going to be very fun swing no
just having time for yourself like i
feel very
fortunate that i have honestly i could
probably work a little more right now
dude so the swing is actually in front
of my
office my room and there's a huge window
and all i see
during the day is david's swinging
outside
as i'm stuck in the room i'm like wow
this guy
is very fortunate and i come out and
i'll be like i'm so tired he's like
me too i was just swinging outside what
the freak
i was swinging all day but you know i
mean
you know what good for you i have to say
i mean you do that and yet you still do
your job and you still get the income
that you need
to do whatever you need to do i mean i
definitely there you go
you know i've been thinking about this
recently too it's like
i feel like sometimes i worked so damn
hard
i almost handicapped myself where i feel
like
work sometimes scares me because i'll
get into this
fervor where it's just overload boom go
go go go go go go go like when i quit jk
news i was like game on
and it was it was work city
out and about all the time working new
content building a new podcast
you know so sell the thriller show i did
i did i worked i went
i auditioned got that indie film i did
the the wish dragon thing
you know oh yeah which he got he got a
role in there oh we didn't even know
yeah i mean this is a side track story
but i so a while back
i did uh i was on this role doing voice
over work right
and i i still have a voiceover agent
right now i haven't gone to audition a
lot just because i'm not really feeling
it
but i do have a knack for it i have a
really good knack for it and i didn't
know that until i started auditioning
and um i got brought in to do voice over
work for
uh a film called the wish dragon it's
actually out on netflix right
now and i have a small spot i make
the voice of a construction worker so
actually i got brought in to do voices
for
literally every male character in that
film so i actually did
like modeled and voiced like the jokes
and a lot of the stuff
for these characters in the film and it
was any kind of male character in there
i did the voice for
but they only kept one and it was the
construction worker and then other
people
you know came in and into the other
voices but it was really it's a really
cool experience but one of the things is
like oh i want to be in an animated film
and i actually thought that i he didn't
use any of my voices
and he used one of them do you still
want to try it out
i think it's very fun voiceover work for
me though it's
extremely fun but it's not um
i don't want to say that it's not
challenging but it's it's just fun stuff
i don't want to make a career at it
because i enjoy it so much you know it's
just really
really cool to do i can sit around and
do voices all day and even when i was in
that first of all the director for wish
dragon he was so
awesome he was number one he made the
the space super comfortable
um he allowed me to be creative he
worked with are you asian
he's a white dude yeah guy was super fun
to work with
and actually wish dragon is a really
good animated film like i was
oh really i have yet to see it we should
watch it together i'll watch it again
yeah but it was it's really cool man and
like i
yeah like during this time i was
hustling really hard and the wish dragon
was one of them and they kept one of my
voices so i have a voice acting credit
now in an animated film
by sony which is really funny you have
credits in
so many places it's like these random
check marks that i'm creating you know
seriously yeah it's on your bucket list
too yeah and it's done now
even if it's small it's like cool i mean
so you've you know
as i'm sitting as i'm stuck in my cell
working away and i see outside and dave
is just swinging there and then he comes
around he's like
yeah i'm tired too i just i was just
waiting outside i'm like
damn i want your life but and then i'm
thinking about what he did in the past
and how much his body fluctuated i think
that shows stress and i was like
it's hard man like that was a hard hard
adventure or
the hard time that you went through as
i'm like
but it was awesome it was also hard for
us too though like when it's
when you focus everything on work
everything falls to the wayside it's
hard to do anything else
because the the stress level from it
that stress level scares me like i
hate thinking that my life is going to
be me stuck in a room again
just creating content 24 7
reading comments looking at the likes
doing what else do i do next who am i
going to collaborate with next
what's the next meeting i'm going to do
should i be in another film should i
start auditioning again
thinking about the stuff stresses me out
i did this for so [ __ ] long
are you still thinking like that i
refuse to it's in the back of my head
though you know
like i could do it again you know people
are like oh why don't you create these
youtube videos again because it's hard
people don't understand too sometimes
like the type of content that i create
that people liked
used to eat at me to sit here have an
opinion about every serious topic in
this world
somehow make it funny and i'm glad it
does great things for everybody else but
i had to think about myself too
like it like when all this stuff too
that i did for
you know asian american hate you know
black lives matter which is stuff that's
very very important to me
and they're like people are sending me
new articles every day
can you do a video about this one can
you do a video about this one it's like
dude
there's a trade-off here it's my sanity
it kills me
it eats me inside it makes me exhausted
makes me hate the world
is it because there's always a negative
argument it's a negative article
it makes me hate people i can't hate
people what if you do the opposite
look into more positive well i am that's
why a lot of these i'm doing this thing
where i'm featuring artists now
like people who don't know them because
it's like hey if i'm going to sit here
and people want me to trash on things
well i'm going to uplift people that i
feel like deserves spotlight
i did this guy reuben i this guy other
guy named jason cheney how do you feel
about
that it makes me feel good like
sometimes too like i know it might not
get a lot of views
but it'll get like whatever 40 000
listings on spotify and
there's a purpose that's a purpose for a
better reason exactly it'll be like 50
000 people that never knew them before
so why not
you know go away it's like um you know
my friend debbie
um she does she makes she's a sushi chef
like you were
i think you were you this was during the
pandemic time how
you know you were thinking of like yeah
i want to help out like small business
and then um her name came around and
then you
were like yeah let's just do it for fun
and then i mean
bless her she works really hard but you
know thanks to you too
like her name really got out there and
she's so successful
and i was like damn this is actually
really cool because i did
see you a lot doing you know that's your
thing it's like
bringing like negative articles or like
weird
like articles where you make them you
make fun of them and then also bring a
lesson out of it but then you're just
like no i just want to do something that
i like to do that doesn't have to do
anything with the world
you did this and yeah that makes me feel
really good
yeah you because i was like oh hey you
know she's doing really well like
everything's getting sold out and
like you don't really express it but
then you're like [ __ ] that
like you i could tell that when you
heard that and you see
the result and also how much hard work
she puts into her job
yeah like you feel so satisfied i saw
that on your face especially for
for somebody like her and even the guy
reuben and
jason like they're very prolific at what
they do this podcast is brought to you
by ipvenish are you browsing the web
are you watching something online or
maybe you're simply reading something
well guess what
your stuff is not encrypted
with a virtual private network and guess
what people have been snooping on all
the freaking stuff that you've been
watching and you've been doing innocent
things but that doesn't matter because
nobody should be up in your business
everybody uses a vpn and i use ipvanish
because they
are the best davis so stamp of approval
put it on your forehead
bam brand you like a filthy filthy cow i
love calzone
here's everything you get with ipvanish
you get an anonymous ip address this
means your personal ip address can't be
tracked by anyone on the web you can
circumvent
any online censorship get protection
when using public wi-fi
and you get 24 7 support so go to
ipvanish.combrain
and claim your 65 savings they have
plans starting
at just 349 or 31.49 a year this is the
time to sign up with our discount and
their current promotional offerings you
can get a vpn
for 65 off their usual offering ipvanish
is the best of the best even rated 4.7
out of 5
on trustpilot and that's with more than
6 thousand reviews show these guys some
love they're repeat sponsors baby
remember it's
ipvanish.com brain
to get the deal and start protecting
yourself online
and they don't play a game that'll allow
them for
for people to see who they are right and
it's hard sometimes in this
in the space because you have to do
crazy stupid [ __ ] for people to notice
you
yeah you can't just be talented you
can't just be good at what you do you
can't
you can't just work on your craft and
people have people respect you for it so
it's like well if i have the platform to
go and talk [ __ ] i can do the opposite
so when debbie did really well it makes
me happy right
when i have nick and alex on and then
nick gets uh clients
and he makes more money from getting
clients and stuff and people come to him
they recognize him
makes me feel good you know this is the
type of stuff that i enjoy
like i might be really good at trashing
people but the stuff that makes me happy
is affecting people in a positive way
and i could start doing with this small
circle of people i'm not going to be on
this space forever
i know this about myself i don't the
reason why i will never be
that great in entertainment is because i
don't like entertainment
what do you mean like i don't enjoy
attention like
i like saying whatever i want and doing
what i do
but the outcome of that is that i get to
make a great living i make a connection
with these people
however i don't yearn to be recognized
for the rest of my life
when somebody looks at me and goes hey
you're washed it doesn't affect me they
go oh you're
like you're not as famous as you used to
be i'm like good
someone says that you know if somebody
did say that which is true like i'm not
nowhere near as
famous as i was before because i don't
put out as much i don't create videos
like that
it doesn't affect me though because my
purpose is different what's your purpose
now
it's just creating whatever that it is
and if it gets recognized it gets
recognized the food stuff makes me feel
good because it's effort that we as a
group of people did to put together and
when people walk away they're happy
they take this drink they enjoy it and
it makes them happy that's what makes me
happy
soft serves the same way people grab the
soft serve they eat it it makes me happy
one of the hardest things that i had to
do with the first softer spot were
people who were food bloggers that
wanted to come in
just so they could take a picture and
they threw away my saucer that [ __ ] used
to piss
me but what if that made them happy i
don't know if it made them happy they
didn't smile
they just they go click they didn't even
try it and they threw it in the garbage
can
oh it was like they literally spit on my
face and i was just like
[ __ ] whatever so you want them
to be happy
consuming that product or at least give
it a try give it a try you know
and that was hard you know but it is
what it is like i can't tell people
how to live their life but if they came
in and they took whatever they could do
whatever they want with it
but this is the like my drive in life is
just to figure out how to be happy
now the goal is to be happy as the goal
is to be happy now i just have to match
my work ethic and drive with it
because right now i think i feel a
little guilt because i'm
i'm playing a little too much and not
working hard enough but
why do you feel that guilt because i
know how much
more i can do but will that make you
happy i don't know
are you happy now i'm pretty damn happy
but i i feel like
uh still there's a part of me because i
i like working hard
that i might look back and say i should
have done a little more
you know because i don't want to live
with regret either but then i think
while i regret that i worked too much
and i didn't play enough you know i'm
like oh [ __ ]
so it's just like it's it's you know
what it is it's first world problems
apologies
it's [ __ ] that is so true these
[ __ ] bitch-ass first world problems
you know that i didn't have before
because before it was like me wanting to
pay my bills and cover my ass
like i i i told you about this the first
apartment that i moved in when i when i
was in pasadena
was this small little spot that i paid
like 200 300 bucks a month and then my
my manager my cousin paid the other part
of it he paid the utilities all i did
was pay for my food
and the rest of the money i bought this
desk at walmart this that was on sale
for 100
that was [ __ ] rickety as [ __ ] i had
this box spring
and this mattress that my parents bought
from sacramento that i slept on
had one bed sheet one blanket one pillow
that's it
i wore free t-shirts and basketball
shorts all the time and that hasn't
changed
yeah and now i have shirts that i buy
instead and basketball shorts
but that's about it i mean it's you know
interesting because now you're at a
stage where maybe
because you've gone through that that
you want
more of the comfort you are willing to
pay for that comfort because like
you know i mean like i kind of i didn't
grow up in a poor environment but like i
grew up just like
not necessarily needing to have like
quality
over quantity or anything like if
there's a floor i'll just sleep there
like i'm really
i remember in college in berkeley my
roommates i forgot to i
forgot my keys to the apartment so i
ended up falling asleep in front of the
apartment and my roommate saw me and
she's like
what are you doing i'm like i fell
asleep i forgot my keys
so i could fall asleep anywhere like i'm
very like i could get by wearing like a
shirt for 10 years like even though like
people you know
it might not like i'm so like practical
in that kind of sense so like when i go
on a trip like i could go and get like
the most like small space airbnb and
also maybe because i'm petite but for
you you're like
if we're gonna go somewhere it better be
comfortable
and i'm like damn he got some like very
expensive taste here
well i mean it's not even expensive it's
relative to what i make right
so it's like but yeah like you're like
i'm not going back to that stage like if
i could provide it myself i'm gonna
utilize it yeah and it's like it's very
few and far between because what do i do
do i buy clothes do i buy shoes anymore
like what do i buy
anymore like i don't i don't really do
any of that stuff now what i do is i buy
stuff from costco all the time which is
food
snacks that's where my money goes you
know i even stopped buying equipment i
don't care about this stuff anymore
now it's just like if i get into a hobby
i buy things and then i
use i make sure i use the [ __ ] what is
your latest hobby now washing cars
yep this is so weird
like he once he's into something he will
buy the
full package it's not even like oh let
me try one thing it's like no
let me have the full package i go to the
garage i'm like what the heck
our garage turned into hey tell me how
nice my car is i mean it's great like he
does he definitely does his homework and
gets
an a-plus on his test i gotta admit that
so that's the good thing i'm like at
least he's using it but
let's see how many times you actually
use it i will well i have to use it a
minimum
of at least three times you said five
five times too many times
okay right three more times on yours two
times online yeah
well now that i've already clay barred
right i clay barred it
i sealed it and i waxed it i don't have
to do that again for another two three
months so now when i wash it it's just
gonna be a washing soap and then
a spray sealant and that's it and that's
fast the reason why the first wash took
so long
is because i had to strip all the
impurities off the car
and then reseal it on top of the clear
coat so that's the part that takes long
the three or four washes after are fast
it's just soap water dry enough sealant
that's it so promising that you'll
actually clean my car too
oh your car's gonna be fast your car's
half the size of my car
so i got it don't worry don't worry at
all
okay when is this gonna happen you say
oh wednesday
wednesday yeah monday tuesday i have
stuff to do but
um but going back to what i was saying
with the whole like remembering
that that whole apartment like oh yeah
yeah like i know i remember that
you know it's like that small apartment
and
just working all the [ __ ] time scared
that i wasn't going to be able to pay my
bills
that's what i remember every [ __ ]
time and i remember i told you about
like how
sometimes it's hard for me to hear other
people complain about all these small
things in life
because i'm very grateful i like to look
at how grateful i am to do what i do
right because no matter how stressed i
get at work i never say i hate what i'm
doing
right i never said i hate my job i don't
say any of this stuff right because
i feel very blessed that i have a
paycheck because i was always scared you
know what my
dude my first girlfriend you you got so
scared one time because
i told her i was like you know what i'm
just gonna quit college and i am just
gonna go
on a bus grab my [ __ ] and this just hit
every [ __ ] comedy club until somebody
knows who the [ __ ] i am that was my goal
like i literally didn't care i was like
[ __ ] safety [ __ ] certainty i just want
to be happy doing what i'm doing
so now the fact that i get to do what
i'm doing now and still make somewhat of
a living off of it
blows my mind every day i wake up and
i'm like dude this is a house
you know i have a i have a podcast room
i was able to do all this other stuff
that wasn't even i wasn't even capable
of like it wasn't
it wasn't possible there was that
japanese restaurant i told you about
matsuri
matsuri was a sushi restaurant that was
walking distance from my very first
apartment
and i only ate there every now and then
because i could barely afford to eat
there
now i went back that i look at the menu
and i'm like this stuff is not that
expensive like this is stuff that i
would pay any day
yeah you upgraded yourself which is kind
of crazy to me
like i was eating cup ramen i was eating
all this other stuff
just because i wanted to save money i
remember the first paycheck that i got
from youtube the paycheck after that and
how much how much money each one was
and it blew my [ __ ] mind till this
day it still blows my mind it blows my
mind that during pandemic my mom was
like oh we can't open up the store for
the next two months
i went cool here's six grand
you gave him only six grand that's how
much she asked
well she actually she asked me well she
asked for like like a
thousand or two thousand like that but i
was like well no take this you know i
want them to know that they're okay
that even if they whatever happens i can
still take care of them so
this is like the world that i live in
and i always talk about this and people
might get sick of it but i always talk
about having being grateful for what you
have
even then when i was broke as [ __ ] going
to matsuri i was grateful that i had a
paycheck enough to even eat at matsuri
right so are you grateful yeah that's
why
i'm swinging on a swing because i'm
happy it's like yo this is crazy
and i i never know how long this stuff
is going to last right
but i think i'm very fortunate enough
that things have been getting better i
have been getting more opportunities
yeah which is crazy and i don't know if
it's going to be like this 10 years from
now
yeah you know but that's why i'm making
sure that i'm covering my ass
i'm jealous of you i wish i could be
like that but i'm not i'm like the
opposite
it's i'm not i mean i'm grateful for the
fact where i
am in terms of like my career but i am
not happy so
that's the problem for me like i want to
swing out there but i can't
my goal is to swing out there but i
can't it's hard it's scary though
right my mom would've said it but my mom
was like i remember when
i was just working all the time right
and my mom saw
how just exhausted i was i would come
home
you would be asleep 14 hours knocked out
and she's like what the hell are you
doing over there
why is it that every time you come to
sacramento you can barely keep your eyes
open i'm like just quiet here i don't
i'm not working i'm not doing anything
yeah
and she was like what are you saving
this money for like what is are you
gonna take this with you you're gonna
die one day she was like who cares she
goes i have worked my job working
i was i helped your dad at the church i
worked at the store
70 out 80 hours a week all this other
stuff
everybody looks at me like oh my god
you're so tired like you you work so
hard
she goes i don't know who they're
pitying i i'm happy
i've never complained about my life i
never complained about going to work
i'm happy when i get to go to work i get
to see these customers that have
supported our business for years
this is joy i have a roof over my head i
have two healthy sons
what is there for me to complain about
so when people talk to me about
not you know their life sucks i really
do believe it's perspective because look
at my parents
they do my dad had so many bad things
happen to him i could do like 8 000
podcasts about my dad's bad luck
but he's never ever complained about
life that's what's crazy to me and i
think it's very important to people to
know for people who do have kids out
there
because my parents never complained
about their life i never complained
about mine
good friends cause i never saw it i
never saw it growing up it wasn't an
example they put in front of me
my mind never once in my life my mom and
dad said i hate my life and i've seen
them fight each other i've seen them
throw [ __ ] break [ __ ]
i see them almost get divorced multiple
times i see my mom run out barefoot
saying that she's gonna walk back to
korea oh my god but even through all
that
the next day she never complained about
life
she was like she moved on from it and
then she was happy
i don't know whether she was doing it
for us or for herself but this is worse
that she told me she goes no matter what
we went through no matter how poor we
were
i was always grateful that i was alive
so
what are you working so hard for so this
is why i don't like people who aren't
grateful i am around certain people in
my life right now that they're slowly
getting cut off because no matter how
great they live their life how much
money they make how
how even from an outside perspective how
everybody else sees it
they always find a [ __ ] reason to
complain about something life is never
good enough
those people can get the [ __ ] away from
me because they're going to be like that
for the rest of their life
every time we hang out oh my god this is
what's wrong with this oh my god what is
this and in my mind i know these people
i'm like [ __ ]
i've known you since you were you had
[ __ ] nothing how
dare you complain how dare you you were
a [ __ ]
nobody what are they complaining is it
that they're not doing
is if complaining about themselves or
complaining about everything
themselves their personal lives
relationships how much money they have
the way their house is the way they're
the way their apartment is the
everything and just
life is never good enough can't be
around people like that if you can't
appreciate the stuff that you have
around you that means you can't
appreciate me you can't appreciate our
friendship and it's been like that
since the since the dawn of time i've
seen that with personal relationships
growing up and i won't
let people like that around me because
that [ __ ] when we have kids they'll
bring that around our kids
you will never bring that [ __ ] around my
kids i like to i like
positive world i like optimistic world
i like i like that i don't like to be in
the negative world
that's why i like that's why you see my
friends are all weird but they're all
very positive
they're very free yeah exactly yeah if
you notice
with money or no money they're all very
just
free carefree yeah they get their [ __ ]
done they work hard whatever i'm like
damn what a life
but they don't complain even some other
ones now that may not have everything
you don't see them complain that we're
always laughing having a good time
trying to figure our ways out
i need that type of energy in my life
interesting
like my friends and i we talk about
we talk about value like how that's like
that could be
that could make us unhappy like
i don't know yeah that's like the
current it's just a
issue for me right now in my circle is
like what is our value
are we being undervalued and if so how
can we
break out of this so that we are not
feeling unhappy or unsatisfied
i think one of the biggest things too
that i figured out that a lot of us
have a problem with is the idea that
failure is not an option
failure is always an option like failure
is something that we're all so scared of
i'm scared of that [ __ ]
constantly yeah and every day i have to
tell myself to shut the hell up
my you're scared of not
but you aren't you're always worried
though i'm always worried oh yeah that's
why i take cbd
it's like oh my gosh um
yeah my friend told me that
i didn't realize this until my friend
told me i i say the word
failed a lot for myself and my friend
was telling me how becky actually she
was telling me how
becky's so funny becky's like you know
you should really not use that word for
yourself because that's
like she was talking about how there's a
study of using that word
really gets your mind gets stuck there's
like no
space for you to learn or to grow
because you just put a dead end to it
and i was like okay i didn't and i just
kind of moved on and then like it kind
of got stuck in my head
of that i was like hmm i wonder if
that's doing something to my mental side
i mean for sure it does remember i
talked about this too and we had this
conversation that
she may be a very bubbly happy person
but sometimes like when these
problems happen in the road where things
don't work out the way that she wants it
to
she beats herself up a lot it's always
like i can't believe i did it this way
why did i do this i'm so dumb
this is stupid like you say this stuff a
lot
to myself yeah i do and out loud i hear
it a lot
yeah a lot and remember what becky says
she goes so becky is an elementary
school teacher
she goes you know you shouldn't say that
stuff about yourself
be nicer to yourself you sound like my
students right now yeah
it's like i can't do anything oh yeah
i'm like i can't do
anything after a small little thing and
she's like you know you sound just like
my student right now i was like
oh great and on the opposite i go like
what the
[ __ ] like don't you say what are you a
little punk ass [ __ ] just
do this [ __ ] like just [ __ ] figure it
out figure this [ __ ] out
do it figure it out figure it out if you
can't do it find somebody else who can
if that person can't do it find somebody
else who can just figure it out figure
it out this is where i think like
how you grow up really does matter
because
let's just say i probably have a great
record of failing
growing up like i probably have a great
like permanent record
of me failing and that's why i had to
prove myself that i'm not a failure and
i
you know graduate got into a college
without anyone's help and
graduated on time with that without
anyone's help so i was like okay i'm not
a failure after all but
you know like 10 15
years of that kind of mentality and you
do end up failing on something
afterwards like
it does hit me really hard i'm like of
course mariel you could you
that's why you always failed on other
things so
it's like
i thought i grew up in a very like free
spirit world but
the more i'm seeing myself the more i'm
catching like understanding who i am
really like how you are raised and what
you hear of yourself and what you tell
yourself is so
important because i did not think that
that would be the issue
like i never thought i would have to
think about oh my god it's because of
this
or like the word fail would be such a a
huge
like trigger i think the one time i made
her really upset
is because like she used to always say
to me that oh i used to be a very bubbly
person
before i met you or whatever and i told
her i was like that's funny because i
think the opposite i
actually think you're a very negative
person remember i said that outside
yes and i was like what the [ __ ] man i
was like
who do you think you are yeah and then
when i looked at i was like you're
actually one of the more negative people
that i've met is because of the way you
speak to yourself
like i fail i'm like damn girl hella
negative
but in your mind how you perceive
yourself was like
i'm hella positive just like for me over
here i'm like
no i'm in my business sense i'm like no
i'm right like i'm just saying stuff i
was like wait hold on a second like
maybe i'm
kind of an [ __ ] in this situation you
know but maybe i've always been kind of
this [ __ ]
you have i've been telling you since day
one i'm like you're so
mean he's like no i'm not like ah
but that said like i'm i'm actually very
positive and optimistic to
others i think it's yourself yeah and
that's the side i get to see all the
time
so yeah that's the thing you witness all
the time yeah so it's just always like
yo why is this going to beat herself up
so much it's not even
like something something yo this [ __ ]
that was stupid huh it's so stupid
that i say stupid no i said it's so
stupid oh
but like for example this is the
funniest [ __ ] dude and i can't help but
laugh sometimes because i
steve always coined this term it's like
sitcom life and you're my sitcom wife
like so she created this pretty dope diy
coffee table
right and i actually like the coffee
table a lot
right and i was i was like okay because
it's i like practicality
it has a lot of storage it was very
inexpensive to make and it rolls around
on wheels
and then we were going to create an
ottoman on top it was whatever but now
it's in the backyard
but because she got a better coffee
table in her opinion
and so she creates this stuff and then
she drills these holes
jill sees screws and she got like these
two inch screws
the plywood is about an inch thick and
it's
shooting up she created this death trap
right
and i look at it and i'm like hey we can
and i started googling stuff like how to
get rid of nails that come out and i was
like oh we could just get
like a election you know what he said
he's like we could just slide i'm like
you're telling me to saw a steal here
you can
so i know but that's so much work yeah
and then you know what she said to me
this
this is the [ __ ] i was like this
conversation is not going anywhere she
goes
she goes what i like it like that i
excuse me she goes what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna buy these clear plastic boxes
and
cover it up and i don't know why she
thought
that covering these spikes shooting out
of a coffee table
like a death trap was smart by covering
it with clear plastic so we could still
see the screws
she goes i like it like that oh my god
this girl just doesn't want to be wrong
right now
see it's that far where in my head i'm
like mario you're such an
idiot you got an inch thick wood and why
would you get a two
inch nail you want to hear something
hella funny so before you built that
table right
you had the screws on there right i told
you this she had these
like long ass screws so me and becky saw
it and we're like
i think we have to get our smaller ones
we i replaced it with shorter screws
and you looked at it and you went this
is not the right one did you move it
and then you got the longer ones i was
like god damn it
you know what's funny i couldn't find
the longer one so i was like huh
maybe it's this one i'm like no i know i
got the longer cut
so i was trying to like because when she
creates diy stuff if i put my
input in it it bothers her right
maybe not so much now but then it was a
problem you probably saw this
yeah so i was like trying to do it in a
way where i don't say anything but help
her out right
but then she was like nah it's supposed
to be these ones
unless it must come out of the wood
that's how i like it
i was shocked i was like joe she refuses
to be wrong on this one
but then after she just goes like i
can't do and i hate this
and [ __ ] the saddest thing she's sitting
on the floor she's trying to stain the
table
right but it wasn't the right stain and
she goes this is so
ugly she's like sad painting this table
i i i i hate this
she's just sitting here like a
five-year-old just like
it's so i don't like it you just pay me
a table
it's just so surprised
oh my god oh my god
oh do you have napkins
i remember that moment
i'm sitting here just in awe like this
woman's world is destroyed
from this diy table
oh my gosh are you like i'm like you
like first the screws
and then the color's not right i should
just throw this away and i'm like it
looks good we just got to soften the
things up
that really ticked me out i was like you
gotta saw these tails are you kidding me
oh my god but do i have black marks all
over okay
oh my god so funny
that's the thing i am very bad with
instructions
but the crazy thing is she's not you're
good
at step-by-step things it's your job
your court
everything is organized but when it
comes to creating things right you go
man [ __ ] these rules
i'm just i get anxiety i'm like what
makes you think you know better
than the video that you're watching
that's telling you how to do this yeah
because what you'll do i see it all the
time she'll watch a video like 20
she goes got it and then she starts
going i'm like
yo hold on a second just
then she's wondering if she gets upset
that it didn't work out she goes
i don't understand why this happened
this way because you're always on 20
of the video it's true i'm like i'll
figure it out
you're like it's not working and then
you're sitting down painting all set
so funny i never learned in that sense
i'm like i'll figure it out i don't
like reading instruction oh my god oh
my god my tears just oh well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast i hope you learned so much
i learned a lot today i learned that i'm
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and uh i'm learning how to be better
with that
and yeah i i i owed my uh my buddy an
apology and i apologized and i said that
he was right which was true
so yeah we're all learning every day man
uh you can see marielle at
mariel underscore underscore songs
mario underscore underscore song at uh
on instagram and you could check out my
harmony
it's a story my harmony
my underscore heart
harmony how much i underscore harmony
she's working on this children's book
about her grandmother
and i'm putting it out there because i'm
putting pressure on her to finish it up
so
uh check that out and then geniusbrain
every thursdays and sundays and we'll
see you all next time